we got this great picture the sun coming
up officially in about six minutes right
now a beautiful view from our camera on
top of the molaski family of companies
building uh this is over on the 95
just off the i-15 as it looks across at
the smith center and the county
government center and of course the
fabulous las vegas trip we may see a
stray high cloud or so the official
temperature 86 at read international
some temperatures drop in some
temperatures staying pretty high 86
along the strip 87 downtown and in
henderson and all of these numbers once
the sun comes up maybe losing another
degree or two before things really do
start cranking up 63 up on the mountain
79 and 79 out at the lakes as well as
centennial hills and sky canyon
checking things out at death valley it's
actually gone up a couple of degrees in
the last hour ely is at 43 good morning
cedar city with your 63 over the up in
prep 77 but speaking of death valley as
john langler mentioned he went out there
yesterday and took this
lovely photograph
118.
what time what time of the day was this
would have been about three o'clock
about three o'clock in the heat of the
day
so your weather headlines we definitely
have that excessive view warning
officially starts at 10 record or near
record temperatures certainly tomorrow
and saturday but the wind comes back on
sunday so over the next couple of hours
we'll have you at 90 by eight over a
hundred at noon 104 at three going for
107 this afternoon that's part of our
almanac looking at the low so far this
morning at 86 our current temperature so
both of these numbers about 10 degrees
above normal no threat to the record
high for today high pressure hanging on
but we're having to keep an eye on some
storm clouds trying to bubble up from
mexico and new mexico and arizona there
may be some chances for some scattered
pop-up storms maybe as far north as
kingman there's still no rain in our
forecast but we're keeping an eye on it
had some severe thunderstorms over
eastern pennsylvania all that is moving
very quickly up into the new england
state so your 8 day forecast all of
these numbers in red those are the
current records for each of the next few
days so 107 today won't be busting the
record but tomorrow if we hit 109 that
will set a new record high for friday's
date if we hit 109 on saturday that will
tie the current record sunday the wind
blows in and the current record of 112
is very likely to stand the wind
continues so technically the wind will
be bringing the temperatures down a few
degrees but that's actually closer to
normal for this time of year